Speaker 1: There is a insane new video of Rudy
Giuliani. We talked about Rudy Giuliani earlier
in the week and just like, do we feel bad
for him? Do we? Not a lot of this current
problems are really of his own doing, choosing
to get involved with Trump and choosing to defend
Trump and choosing to fly around the country,
filing these bogus complaints and holding bogus
hearings related to the 2020 election. And Rudy
Giuliani is potentially in a bunch of trouble now.
He still appears to be sort of maintaining his
loyalty to Trump, at least for now, even though
for most reports we've seen Trump has more or
less abandoned Rudy Giuliani, and the latest is
that Rudy Giuliani claims to have evidence related
to Hillary Clinton in either his bedroom or his
den. Now, then we could talk about Is it Dana
living room, but maybe without a television or
how do we define den doesn't really matter, Rudy
says on Newsmax. He has evidence in his bedroom,
and then he says, Actually, it's in my den. And
everything about this is really weird because it
is essentially a confession from Rudy Giuliani,
which I will explain. HuffPost reports Rudy
Giuliani reveals location of secret evidence
Stash, the former New York City mayor, makes
a weird confession on live TV. Giuliani declared
Tuesday he has a stash of secret evidence against
former Secretary of State Hillary Clinton, and
it's in his bedroom. And then he says, Actually,
it's in my DNA. This was an interview on the right
wing Newsmax network. He says he has a thousand
pieces of evidence that no one has seen. And of
course, as you might remember, Rudy Giuliani's
home and Rudy Giuliani's office were raided. And
so if there is quote evidence there, it raises
the question as to did he legally hold that back
or hide it in some way? Here is Rudy on Newsmax
explaining to us exactly where the evidence is.
Speaker 2: Well, how do I think Trump knew
it and knew about it back then? I can't tell you
exactly how, but I know how he knew about it back
then. There's a lot more to come out. This is
not, I mean, what you're they may feel that it's
gobbledygook, but it's gobbledygook supported
by about a thousand pieces of evidence, none
of which have been revealed yet. I happen to have
it in my bedroom or my agenda, actually, if I had
it there for years, as well as the last election.
Speaker 1: So there's a bunch of different things
here, and it all is the continued self-inflicted
damage being done by Rudy Giuliani. First
question. Did he break the law by withholding this
supposed evidence like this is if if he if the
evidence exists, right? And I know you guys all
the first thing is, is this even in the universe
of truth? If it is, did Rudy Giuliani break
the law by withholding this supposed evidence?
That's question number one. Second question is
he willing to present this supposed evidence
in court while under oath? Because all of these
guys and gals for years claimed to have all of
this evidence here, they're the other place.
It's always imminently going to be released and
this will be Hillary Clinton's undoing, or this
will be Joe Biden's undoing, or this will be the
vindication of Trump. We've got the evidence and
then it never actually gets released or presented
or introduced in any kind of serious way under
oath in a court of law or submitted as an exhibit.
And it's very common for these right wingers to
claim. They have evidence and that it's it's just
about to come out and then we never see it and
look at what happened with the 2020 election,
they've been claiming on the 2020 election that
they have evidence that's going to just blow the
socks off of this election. It'll flip Arizona,
it'll flip Michigan, it'll flip Georgia. It's
mind blowing what they have. They've been claiming
it for 15 months and it never does. And if they
have it, they've also not included in any of
the court filings related to the 2020 election,
all of which are found to be without merit. And
it's very similar with other liars and grifters.
Mike Pillow, Mike Lindell, the CEO of MyPillow. He
has mountains of evidence, he has cyber evidence,
he has forensic evidence, voting machines,
all of this different stuff. And nobody has
seen it. Nobody has seen it. So then you have
to step back and think about the political.
Donald Trump has been running against Hillary
Clinton since 2015, and he continues to run
against her, even though he's not running for
anything and she's not running for anything.
He continues the Hillary Clinton stuff. Do any of
us believe that if Rudy Giuliani had a thousand
pieces of evidence against Hillary Clinton, it
wouldn't have come out when Trump was actually
running against her? Come on, guys, it doesn't
make any sense, and this stuff plays really well
on the conservative news channels, but obviously
they would have used the evidence if they had it
at any time during the 2016 campaign during
the 2020 campaign. Recently, the goal right now
is distraction and distortion. Things are not
looking good for Giuliani things. It hasn't
been a particularly good week to two weeks for
Donald Trump. What would the flushing documents
down the toilet and all of these other different
things? And it is obfuscation, distraction,
distortion. Look at this shiny thing I claim
exists, but there's no evidence it actually
does. If you believe that Rudy genuinely has
evidence about anything, honestly at this point,
find me on Twitter at David Pakman and let me
know what you think he has, but more importantly,
why he has not yet released that I
look forward to hearing from you.